ALLENARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
WELL. GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHIANG DOLLY DODD TO
ROSS SO GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROW HERTZBERG HILL
HUESO FURTADO JACKSON JONES
LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING
MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO INNER.
STERN I'M BURKE WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER WILK. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL
BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BUYER CHAPLAIN SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. BY
SENATOR ALAN. SO LET US RECALL
THOSE WE'RE ALWAYS IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. AND OUR PRAYER TODAY
IS FROM RED BIG ENOUGH COMMON
OF BREAST SLOUGH. AND HE LIVED
IN THE SEVENTEEN HUNDREDS
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS. PATIENTS
GODS. TEACH US TO BE PATIENT.
UNRUFFLED BY THOSE WHO ANGER
TOLERANT OF THOSE SO
EXASPERATED. ACCEPTING OF THOSE
WHO DISAPPOINT. HELP US REMAIN
SERENE AND THE FACE OF DERISION.
CALM IN THE FACE OF PROVOCATION.
COMPOSED IN THE MIDST OF A
STORM. AND DEAR GODS TEACH US
TO BE PATIENT WITH OURSELVES A
MAN. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALUTING OUR NATION'S FLAG I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
YEAH AND. TO ONE- INDIVISIBLE
WITH LIBERTY AND. YOU WILL.
MEMBERS AS WE START THIS WEEK
WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO LET OUR FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS IN AUSTRALIA KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA STANDS BY THEM
IN THESE CHALLENGING TIMES WE
TO HAVE BEEN STRUCK WITH
TERRIBLE DEVASTATING WILDFIRES
AND SO WE HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH SO WE
WANT THEM TO KNOW THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. STANDS
WITH THEM. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
GOVERNOR'S VETOES WILL BE
STRICKEN FROM THE DAILY FILE
FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH FIFTY
ONE GOVERNOR'S VETOES ARE
SISTINE. SENATOR LABOR WILL
MOVE AB TEN SIXTY SIX ITEM
FIFTY THREE TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. INTRODUCTION AND FIRST
READING OF BILLS. MADAM
SECRETARY. SENATE BILL EIGHT OH
EIGHT EIGHT OR. 981-011-8128
THIRTEEN EIGHT FOURTEEN SECOND
READING WILL BE DEEMED READ
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AS WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR A JOURNEY
MEMORIES SENATOR GLAZER NOT AT
HIS DESK. WIENER WIENER. NOT AT
HIS DESK SENATOR CHIANG. NOT AT
HER DESK SENATOR SKINNER I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE I THOUGHT YOU
KNOW OKAY. SENATOR RUBIO NOT AT
HER DESK SENATOR HER TITLE
WE'RE SO HAPPY YOU'RE AT YOUR
DESK PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES IT
IS WITH A HEAVY HEART I ASKED
WE ADJOURN TODAY'S MEETING IN
MEMORY OF COUNCIL MEMBER.
REMEMBER MY FROM THE CITY OF
QUIRK TREND HE WAS SIXTY SIX
YEARS OLD. NOT ONLY WAS RATE
BELOVED COUNCIL MEMBER FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS RAY WAS A SON
HUSBAND GRANDFATHER. BEERS
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE. WRITER
ADVISER AND RETIRED EDUCATOR
FOR THIRTY EIGHT YEARS AT
CORCORAN HIGH SCHOOL. RAY WAS
ONE OF NINE CHILDREN BORN TO
GROUPS AND DADDY YOUR LETTER
MAYA WHO SPENT THEIR TIME
MIGRATING UP AND DOWN
CALIFORNIA'S FARMWORKERS
WORKING TO SUSTAIN THEIR FAMILY.
A COMMUNITY MAN RAY WILL BE
BEST REMEMBERED FOR GATHERING
HIS HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS TO
CLEAN UP PARKS OR HIGHWAYS.
ATTENDING COUNCIL MEETINGS
SERVING WITH THE KINGS COUNTY
COMMUNITY ACTION ORGANIZATION.
THE CITIZENS ADVISORY COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN FOR THE CORPORATE AND
KINGS COUNTY ASSOCATION OF
GOVERNMENTS AND CHAIR OF THE
KINGS COUNTY LATINO ROUND TABLE.
RAY WAS NOT AFRAID TO FIGHT FOR
HIS COMMUNITY AS A RETIRED
EDUCATOR RATE WAS CURRENTLY
TEACHING ENGLISH AT THE ADULT
SCHOOL TO CORCORAN RESIDENTS
WHO ARE PREPARING TO TAKE THEIR
CITIZENSHIP TEST. RAY WAS ALSO
PASSION ABOUT ENSURING THAT
RESIDENTS HAD ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE AND WANTED TO PROVIDE
BETTER ACCESS TO DIALYSIS
PATIENTS. HE WAS WORKING WITH
LOCAL HEALTH CLINICS TO EXPAND
HOURS OF SERVICE GIVEN THAT THE
NEAREST HOSPITAL WAS FORTY
MINUTES IS FORTY MINUTES AWAY.
ACCESS TO CLEAN AND SAFE WATER
WAS ANOTHER MAJOR PROJECT FOR
HIM. JUST THIS PAST MONTH UP I
HAD MET WITH HIM AND CITY STAFF
TO DISCUSS CHALLENGES TO WATER
ACCESS AND COST. COUNCILMEMBER
LERMA WILL BE GREATLY MISSED
FOR HIS COMMITMENT AS AN
ADVOCATE TO CORCORAN KINGS
COUNTY FOR HIS ABILITY TO FIND
WAYS TO UPLIFT. THE LIVES OF
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE LATINO
COMMUNITY AROUND HIM. AUSTIN
POWER COUNCILMEMBER LERMA.
THANK YOU SENATOR HER TITLE
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD
SO WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED SENATOR GLAZER I
BELIEVE YOU HAD AN INTERNAL
MEMORY. PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. RIGHT MADAM PRESIDENT-
AND MEMBERS- IT'S WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I ASK THE SENATE
TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF HOBBY-
RAMIREZ AND TWIN BROTHERS MARC
ANTHONY ARISTA AND MICHAEL
ANGELO ARISTA. STUDENTS FROM MY
DISTRICT. WHO TRAGICALLY LOST
THEIR LIVES IN A CAR CRASH ON
CHRISTMAS EVENING. HOBBY YEAR
MARK AND MICHAEL WERE ALL ONLY
SIXTEEN YEARS OLD. THEY LIVED
IN DUBLIN CALIFORNIA WERE
STUDENTS TO DOUBLE IN HIGH
SCHOOL- IN THAT CRASH TO OTHER
STUDENTS SUFFERED MAJOR
INJURIES AND MY THOUGHTS ARE
WITH THEM AS WELL. HOBBY YEAR
MARK AND MICHAEL WERE VERY WELL
LOVED BY THEIR FELLOW STUDENTS
FRIENDS- AND- CLASSMATES- THEY
WERE FINE LOVABLE AND CARING
INDIVIDUALS A HOBBY OR WAS A
SOCCER PLAYER WITH THE DUBLIN
UNITED SOCCER LEAGUE MARK HAD A
CONTAGIOUS SMILE AND INSPIRED
TO BE A REALTOR LIKE HIS MOM.
AND MICHAEL WAS CHARISMATIC AND
FUNNY HOBBY YEAR MARK AND
MICHAEL WERE A GREAT
SUPPORTERS- FOR FRIENDS AND MEN
INVOLVED IN IN THE COMMUNITY AS
WELL ON THE NIGHT OF THE
ACCIDENT. THEY WERE OUT TO HELP
A FRIEND ACCORDING TO THEIR
TWINS MOM AND EVERY NOW SO. AND
MARKET MICHAEL WOULD OFTEN HELP
KIDS FROM MILITARY OR SINGLE
PARENT HOUSEHOLDS BY CONNECTING
THEM WITH OTHERS IN THE
COMMUNITY- MY DEEP CONDOLENCES
TO HOBBY YEARS PERRANCE. HOBBY
ERR SENIOR AND SO WE AYE QUE.
AND TO MARKET MICHAEL'S PARENTS
ANDREW YOU'RE RESET AND ANNA
RIGHT NOW SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE SENATE
ADJOURNED AND THEY'RE-
WONDERFUL MEMORY. THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER PLEASE BRING ALL
THREE NAMES FORCE WE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE THEM.
SENATOR WINNER ABBREVIATED
JOURNAL MEMORY. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I'M COLLEAGUES
AT TODAY I AM. ASKING THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY- REGARDING- A
DEATH THAT CAN OWN THIS IS.
BEYOND HORRIFIC- SO AND SO IS
INCREDIBLY TRAGIC FOR THE
COMMUNITY- HOW LONG YOUR KHïI
ALSO KNOWN AS GRANDMA ALONG.
WITH WHO WAS BORN ON FEBRUARY
FIFTEENTH NINETEEN THIRTY- DIED
ON JANUARY THIRD OF THIS YEAR.
HI GRANDMA LONG WAS BORN INTO A
SIGN CHINA AND IMMIGRATED TO
SAN FRANCISCO IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX APPROXIMATELY ONE
YEAR AGO IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. AT ABOUT SIX AM OUR
GRANDMA LONG LONG WAS BRUTALLY
ATTACKED WHEN SHE WAS DOING HER
ROUTINE EXERCISES IN SAN
FRANCISCO AT THE VISITATION
VALLEY PLAYGROUND RIGHT ACROSS
THE STREET FROM HER HOME. WHICH
WAS AN BROKEN INTO AND LOOTED
FOLLOWING THE ATTACK. SHE WAS
ABOUT NINETY YEARS OLD. HI
GRANDMA LONG SUFFERED FACIAL
AND SKULL FRACTURES AS WELL AS
A BRAIN INJURY IN THIS BRUTAL
ATTACK AND SHE WAS HOSPITALIZED
FROM THEN UNTIL HER DEATH A
YEAR LATER. SHE SUFFERED
THROUGH MASSIVE PAIN AND HAVING
COURAGEOUSLY CLINGING TO LIFE
FOR A YEAR WHEN SHE PASSED.
AFTER THE ATTACK HI GRANDMA
LONGS GRANDDAUGHTER SOCIETY
ORGANIZED COMMUNITY SUPPORT FOR
MORE POLICE PATROLS IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD WITH CHINESE
SPEAKING OFFICERS- THERE'S
ALSO- BEEN EFFORT TO SECURE
MORE MONEY FOR A POLICE
SUBSTATION IN THE VISITATION
VALLEY NEIGHBORHOOD. AND MORE
RESOURCES FOR NEIGHBORHOOD
WATCH PROGRAM THAT I HOPE THAT
THESE THINGS HAPPEN. HASSAN AND
OTHER COMMUNITY ADVOCATES HAVE
ALSO ORGANIZED A RALLY ON MARCH
A SILENCE SIT IN AT THE
PLAYGROUND WHERE THE ATTACK
HAPPENED AND OTHER PEACEFUL
COMMUNITY ACTIVITIES NOT ONLY
TO SUPPORT GRANDMA LONG AND HER
MEMORY- BUT ALSO TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
ISSUES ESPECIALLY CRIMINAL
VIOLENCE DIRECTED AT WOMEN AND
SENIORS IN OUR COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY SENIORS. WHO SIMPLY
CANNOT DEFEND THEMSELVES A GRAM
OF HUANG'S FUNERAL WILL BE HELD
ON JANUARY NINETEENTH. SHE IS
SURVIVED BY FOUR ADULT CHILDREN
LEE AND JENNY HELLO AND JENSEN-
SHE SURVIVED BY EIGHT
GRANDCHILDREN AND FIVE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN THIS IS A
TERRIBLE TRAGEDY FOR OUR OUR
COMMUNITY I WANT TO SEND OUT MY
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES. TO THE
FAMILY AND THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY- I RESPECTFULLY OUT
SO WE ADJOURN AND GRANDMA LONGS
MEMORY. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO WE CAN PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE HER. SENATOR CHIANG
I BELIEVE YOU HAD AN ATTORNEY
MEMORY PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF THE LIFE
OF FORMER YOUR BELINDA MAYOR
HANK OUIDA. HANK WAS FIRST
ELECTED TO THE YOUR BILL IN THE
CITY COUNCIL IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY AFTER DECORATED CAREER
IN THE US ARMY AIR FORCE AND
MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS OF WORK
WITH THE ENERGY ENGINEERING
DEPARTMENTS OF ARROW JET.
MARTIN AND NORTHROP. IN HIS
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS OF
SERVICE YOUR BILL IN A CITY
COUNCIL INCLUDING FIVE AS
MAYOR. HANK WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
THE GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT OF
THE CITY. HE AS KNOWN FOR HIS
ADVOCACY COMPASSION AND SUPPORT
OF HIS COMMUNITY. WHILE SERVING
ON YOUR ROLE IN THE CITY
COUNCIL IN AS PART OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS. HANK FOUNDED
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOOK FAIRS
WHICH SOLD BOOKS TO CHILDREN
THROUGH TRAVELING SCHOOL BOOK
FAIRS. IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
HE SOLD THE BUSINESS TO
SCHOLASTIC INCORPORATED A MAJOR
NEW YORK PUBLISHER OF
CHILDREN'S BOOKS. ONE OF THE
PASSIONS OF HANK'S LIFE WITH
CLEAN AIR HE BECAME A MEMBER OF
THE GOVERNING BOARD OF THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WHERE HE
SERVED A PERIOD OF SEVEN YEARS
INCLUDING THREE YEARS AS
CHAIRMAN. IN THAT TIME AND
SUBSEQUENTLY IN OTHER ROLES
HANK PLAYED AN INTEGRAL PART IN
ADVOCATING FOR THE PRESERVATION
OF OUR REGIONAL AIR QUALITY
THAT HE RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF
OUR MOST CRITICAL.
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES. IN
TWO THOUSAND AND NINE HE
RECEIVED CALIFORNIA'S AIR
RESOURCES BOARD PRESTIGIOUS
HAGEN SMITH CLEAN AIR AWARD FOR
HIS CAREER ACHIEVEMENTS AND AIR
QUALITY ISSUES OVER THE YEARS.
MORE IMPORTANT THAN ANY OF
THOSE IMPRESSED CAREER
ACHIEVEMENTS SO WAS HANK'S LOVE
FOR HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
JOINING THE MEMORY OF HANK
OUIDA. THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG
PLEASE REFER TO BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. SENATOR RUBIO I
BELIEVE YOU HAD AN ADJOURNED.
FOR SEE WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
PRESIDENTE MEMBERS TODAY I RISE
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF LIEU
FOR OUR WHO WAS A LEADER IN OUR
COMMUNITY IN A LONG TIME COACH
AT CHARTER OAK HIGH SCHOOL IN
THE CITY OF COVINA FOR OUR WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH LEUKEMIA IN
APRIL OF TWENTY NINETEEN AND
AFTER MANY MONTHS OF BATTLING
THIS HORRIBLE DISEASE HE PASSED
AWAY THIS PAST NOVEMBER HE WAS
A LOVING HUSBAND FATHER
EDUCATOR AND LEGENDARY COACH
AND HIS COMMUNITY WHO GUIDED
CARE FOR AND INSPIRED
GENERATIONS OF FOOTBALL
PLAYERS. AND STUDENTS I HAD THE
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE OF ATTENDING
A CEREMONY WHERE THEIR STADIUM
WAS DEDICATED AFTER LOW THE
LOVE THE RESPECT AND ADMIRATION
FROM TEACHERS OTHER COACHES AND
STUDENTS WAS EVIDENT THIS
UPCOMING SEASON WHAT HAPPENED
HAS FIFTY THIRTY YEAR OF
COACHING AND FORTY EIGHT SEASON
OF CHARTER OAK AT CHARTER OAK
AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COACH HIS GRANDSONS AND HIS SON
DOMINATE COULD LATER ENDED UP
BEING HIS ASSISTANT COACH AND
ATHLETIC DIRECTOR OF THE SAME
HIGH SCHOOL. OTHER COACHES IN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT BUT OFTEN
SAY THAT IT WAS A DIFFICULT
PLEASURE TO COACH AGAINST LOU
BECAUSE HIS TEAMS ARE ALWAYS
WELL PREPARED AND HARD TO BEAT
BEFORE BECOMING A COACH FOR OUR
WAS ALSO AN EDUCATOR WHO TAUGHT
PSYCHOLOGY CIVICS A ROYAL OAKS
HIGH SCHOOL WHERE HE FIRST
BEGAN COACHING HIS COACHING
CAREER HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE NANCY SON DOMINIQUE
DAUGHTER NATALIE AND HIS SIX
GRANDCHILDREN. FRAUD
DEMONSTRATED LEADERSHIP COURAGE
AND DEDICATION HE WILL BE
MISSED AND I ASKED EVERY WE
ACTUALLY CLOSE ON HIS BEHALF
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO PLEASE BRING HIS SAME
FORWARDS WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED CENTER SKINNER I
JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR YOU DID
NOT HAVE AN ATTORNEY MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS IF
THERE IS NO FOR THAT SENATOR
HERTZBERG. FOR PURPOSES OF
ANNOUNCEMENT TO. MADAM
PRESIDENT TO ONE OF OUR
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES. CELEBRATED
A BIRTHDAY YESTERDAY. FROM THE
GREAT COMMUNITY OF GUARDINO US
SENATOR BRADFORD CELEBRATED A
BIRTHDAY YESTERDAY AND WE ARE
AFTER UPON THE GERMANS. WILL BE
HAVING CAKE IN ROOM TWO OH FIVE
NINE. THANK YOU MENTION THANK
YOU CENTER HERTZBERG HAPPY
BIRTHDAY SENATOR BRADFORD
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS CENTER PRO TEM. THE
DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND I ILL SEE YOU
ON FRIDAY NOT THURSDAY FRIDAY
JANUARY SEVENTEENTH AT NINE AM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO
TEM MEMBERS HAVE A GREAT REST
OF THE DAY